[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 soy álvaro cordero la invasión
de ucrania por parte de rusia ha sido la
decisión más condenada en los 22 años
que vladimir putin lleva al frente de
rusia un movimiento arriesgado por parte
del kremlin que solo se puede entender
si se profundiza en su figura y en la
línea política que el mandatario ha
impuesto en rusia en este tiempo los
inicios en política de vladimir putin
están en la rusia postsoviética de los
90 en aquella época el país estaba
comandado por boris yeltsin y sufría una
profunda crisis la caída de la urss
había traído dificultades económicas
enfrentamientos internos y una pérdida
de protagonismo es aquí cuando tras un
meteórico ascenso en moscú un
desconocido antiguo agente del canje ve
en alemania oriental llamado vladimir
putin se convirtió en primer ministro el
9 de agosto de 1999 y poco después
reemplazó a y el sinn como presidente su
popularidad creció exponencialmente con
el inicio de la segunda guerra chechena
recién llegado putin inició una ofensiva
militar contra los separatistas
chechenos frente a los que moscú había
perdido una primera guerra entre
1995 y 1996 la nueva ofensiva causó
decenas de miles de muertos civiles y
finalmente grozny quedó bajo control pro
ruso a principios del año 2000 es en
este contexto cuando putin arrasó en los
comicios presidenciales del año 2000 el
objetivo político de su primer mandato
fue consolidar su poder interno a través
de tres líneas controlar a los oligarcas
rusos e impedir su interferencia
política marginar cualquier tipo de
oposición real y seguir combatiendo a
los separatistas chechenos aunque putin
en un principio apoyó a occidente en
momentos clave comenzó a dibujar una
línea en política exterior diferente a
la de yeltsin para el final de su
mandato en 2004 la mayoría de los
desafíos internos estaban controlados y
putin fue reelegido presidente fue
entonces cuando su visión exterior
empezó a manifestarse su objetivo de
consolidar el poder del kremlin en los
países del espacio postsoviético se vio
amenazado por prooccidentales como la
revolución de las rosas en georgia o la
revolución naranja en ucrania
acontecimientos a los que putin acusó de
estar promovidos por occidente a partir
de 2005 su discurso hacia la otan
también se endureció al criticar sus
ampliaciones hacia el este de europa
bolsita but vemos más y más como se
ignoran los principios básicos del
derecho internacional como las reglas y
el sistema completo de un estado
esencialmente de eeuu ha sobrepasado sus
fronteras nacionales en todas las áreas
y para su diversión activo k9cuisine la
economía en la política en lo
humanitario todo está impuesto por un
solo estado nunca muy dope andrés tras
este discurso de 2007 sus intenciones de
proteger los intereses de rusia en el
exterior se hicieron más evidentes en
2008 inició una guerra con georgia con
el argumento de proteger a los gobiernos
separatistas pro rusos de las regiones
de abjasia y osetia del sur para este
momento putin había dejado ya de ser
presidente por el límite de mandatos y
volvió a ser primer ministro aunque su
poder en la sombra continuó afianzándose
hasta a la presidencia en 2012 a su
regreso a la jefatura del estado tenía
asegurados dos mandatos más de seis años
cada uno entretanto los países bálticos
y varios países del este habían
ingresado a la otan 2014 marcó un
quiebre en la actuación de putin en el
exterior en febrero un presidente pro
ruso en ucrania fue derrocado por
masivas protestas conocidas como el euro
maidán y reemplazado por un gobierno
nacionalista y pro europeo
putin rechazó las aspiraciones de
ucrania de acercarse a occidente y
reaccionó anexionando crime a una región
ucraniana de mayoría rusa tras un
referéndum y dando apoyo militar y
económico a los separatistas del donbass
ucraniano también poblado
mayoritariamente por rusos las sanciones
que impusieron eeuu y sus aliados no
hicieron retroceder a putin sin embargo
sus intervenciones no solamente se
centraron en los países del espacio
postsoviético
llegaron hasta siria en 2015 putin entró
en la guerra civil de esta nación en
favor de su presidente bashar al-assad
un histórico aliado
rusia había perdido influencia durante
las últimas décadas en medio oriente y
había visto como aliados tradicionales
como sadam husein o muammar al-gaddafi
habían caído por los intereses de
occidente por lo que se involucró de
lleno en el papel de defensa del
gobierno sirio un apoyo fundamental que
permitió que al asad aguantará en el
poder esta expansión internacional ha
ido de la mano junto con un control
interno prácticamente absoluto en la
última década su mayor desafío fue el
político alexéi navalni a quien acusó de
ser un agente occidental y persiguió
sistemáticamente en 2020 el opositor
presentó síntomas de envenenamiento por
uno que un agente nervioso que los
rusos han usado en otras ocasiones tras
su detención en 2021 su voz ha sido
prácticamente silenciada ahora en su
proyecto de construir lo que llama la
nueva rusia putin ha negado la
existencia de ucrania como estado y
alegando que la dirigen nazis y
drogadictos y que es parte del espacio
histórico ruso tomó la decisión de
invadir la al interior de rusia se
presenta como una operación militar
especial y los pocos medios
independientes que quedaban en el país y
varios medios extranjeros han sido
silenciados por una legislación
draconiana un último paso por ahora que
ha puesto a europa ante el conflicto y
una crisis de refugiados que amenaza con
convertirse en la mayor desde la
posguerra con esto concluimos gracias
por compartir y comentar estas historias
que las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]